[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انه الكاس اسيا صعبه لكن نتمنى ان شاء
الله وهذا طبعا بلادي الثاني لفلسطين كلنا
مع فلسطين للقلوب فنتمنى
ان نشاهدهم باقرب مرحله ممكن ان يوصلوا
فيها المنتخب الفلسطيني بدعو والله ينصرهم
الله ينصرهم على الاحتلال والله ينصرهم في
البطو في البطوله وان شاء الله الله يوفق
جميع المنتخبات الع ان شاء الله ان
المنتخب فلسطيني يقدم نتائج طيبه وباذن
الله تعالى يعني الله يفرحهم ويفرحنا
جميعا ان شاء الله رغم الحزن الموجود
اتمنى طبعا كعراقي اتمنى الفريق العراقي
طبعا وان شاء الله يكون هذا بس اتمنى
الفرق العربيه الاخرى ان شاء الله في
فلسطين اتمنى فلسطين يعني فد مستوى يعني
يطمح يفرح يعني قلوب الجماهير الفلسطينيه
في غزه يعوضهم عن الالام والماسي اللي
يشوفوها ان شاء الله نتمنى الفريق
الفلسطيني التعويض في هذا المناسبه ان شاء
الله